hello freak [ __ ] sorry
and it's 4:30 in the morning you should
never be up at 4:30 still trying to get
laid that's what happens you start doing
the coke and all sudden you went to a
bar that closed you went to another bar
you're [ __ ] thrown down casually you
haven't even gotten laid yet and you're
still chick then she wants to go to
Denny's and then you got to go hang out
at her house and she wants to do more
coke and then also at 4:30 in the
morning it's not you don't even give a
[ __ ] anymore
it's like it's got to happen in the
first two hours you know was a horrible
one for me in the summer when this would
happen and I had jobs so it'd be like
4:30 in the morning yeah and I'd be
still trying to get laid and then I had
to be up at 7:00 to go to my
construction job oh so you'd be carrying
wood all day exhausted and he didn't
shower so you get that oily [ __ ]
stank and your undercarriage your ball
sack is sticking to your thigh I come
home and fall asleep before I even got
my clothes off I just hit the [ __ ]
bed sideways out cold yeah wake up in
the morning do it all over again oh yeah
I used to park cars at a country club
and we would go out all we would get
paid in cash tips we'd make a good 150
bucks in cash I was 16 17 years old we
go out to the bars do shots all night
get laid we go skinny-dipping there was
a pool that we'd break into and it was a
bunch of teenagers that would all skinny
dip on any given night in the summer if
it was hot out you go to that pool there
was naked teenagers swimming and you
could get laid pretty easily and then we
would go and then we'd have to be there
at 6 o'clock in the morning to park cars
because the golfers game and we get
there and we had this little wooden
shack and we'd run up and down the
stairs parking these cars it was down a
hill so you'd have to drive it down the
hill run up drive it down the hill for
hours and then finally they'd all be out
on the golf course kick back in that
Shack and just [ __ ] lay on the wooden
floor and sleep for a couple hours Oh
working when you're tired your kid is so
important yeah it's so important to
realise how to power through things you
don't power through [ __ ] when you're a
little kid I mean they make you take
naps
quite the opposite of power and through
yeah like are you tired lik Greg just
take a nap you need to take it no I
don't wanna go take a nap is take a nap
at school remember that he's have nap
times yeah
then you take a nap when you gonna then
all the sudden no more naps
I'll sudden have to work but it happens
over the course of like a couple of
years yeah now you got to get up at six
those summer jobs those are the big
eye-opener for me that's when I knew
that's when I [ __ ] really knew I
could never work construction that's
when I really knew like summer jobs when
I was in high school and right out of
high schools like [ __ ] this yeah cuz I
know it's true you should bust you
should make your kid bust his ass in
high school so he can realize he needs
an education or he need to pick
something to do young you got to pick
something do different cuz I had other
jobs that weren't as hard like I worked
at Newport Creamery and I was a
dishwasher and then I was a cook wasn't
that hard I mean it sucked it wasn't fun
be cook burgers make ice cream like
sundaes and [ __ ] and milkshakes and
before that I was the guy wash the
dishes I moved up nice on out bro I
didn't want to take the waitress job
though too much responsibility to be a
waiter or waitress lipstick yeah I
didn't look good in those tights but
that was like my only job that I'd had
until I started doing construction jobs
yeah my dad's an architect my stepdad
got me gigs he's an architect and he got
me gigs in the summer like like real
jobs and I was like holy [ __ ] I mean
you're a laborer you're a 16 year old
laborer on a construction site [ __ ] your
life yeah [ __ ] my life every day [ __ ]
your life mm-hmm and plus I didn't know
how to hydrate back down I never drank
any water I drank like a coke in the
morning and then all day no drinking
what no awareness wear any sunblock
how's bronze like copper yeah and I
would just [ __ ] carry [ __ ] all day
and be so tired but I remember thinking
okay you got there's got to be a [ __ ]
plan we got to make a plan
to avoid this can't be doing this yeah
you guys that would do this my friend
Leroy got me a job once this was a
really important turning point him his
friend Hank they would renovate
buildings in Dorchester is real [ __ ]
neighborhood real bad
these buildings were like basically like
completely wrecked and they would redo
them and this one guy he was like semi
homeless he lived in this place while
they were redoing it and he had a
mountain Dew jug or a two liter thing of
Mountain Dew that he filled with malt
liquor he would just drink this Mountain
Dew jug of malt liquor all day he'd be
just blasted all day on the construction
site and we're walking around this like
exposed beams there's to the left and
the right there's fiberglass
you know that's over lattice yeah it
stepped through and you just drop right
through the floor below yeah and this
[ __ ] guy walked like a ballerina
drunk as [ __ ] his name is Jeff never
forget Jeff walked around this this
construction site and just barely not
stepping on nails just barely and drunk
yeah hammered everybody knew it shakes
his hands would shake just hold the
mountain leader the to meet leader
mountain do thing and yeah [ __ ]
shaken while I was trying to drink Wow
full-on alkie and you were like that's
my future I think was my future but I
knew it could be a future if he did with
that guy's dealing like whoa yep yeah
you realize that you know with I had a
job I was actually in college but one
summer I went out to the Hamptons me and
my brother and this other guy from
Northern Ireland Sean he was [ __ ]
drunk and we shared a studio apartment
flea-ridden first two guys in got the
fold-out couch third guy was on the
floor so you try to [ __ ] get home
where the other guys with fleas please
all summer did you guys have a dog did
someone have a dog no somebody must had
a dog before the place was infested and
I would go down my job was I would ride
my bike and I remember it was six miles
I would ride my bike to the beach and I
had to get there at like 7 o'clock in
the morning and it was an outdoor beach
club it was a bar basically Brooklyn
would unload and show up at this place
it was called summers on dune Road in
the Hamptons and they had two outdoor
bars that each had six bartenders in it
how you know power pouring like [ __ ]
Tom Cruise in cocktail chicks and
bikinis bartending and then inside two
more bars with six more bartenders
speakers the size of a [ __ ]
Volkswagen so I get there at 7:00 a.m.
my job was get the [ __ ] dolly and get
10 speakers outside that we're all the
size of Volkswagens plug him in first
thing was do that and then I put on 2001
Space Odyssey at 9:00 to clear off all
the drunks that were sleeping on the
sand from the night before because you
had to pay to get in so they wanted to
clear the [ __ ] Beach all these people
get up scream with their hands on and
then I would carry up me and the other
guy would carry up racks you know booze
racks with like [ __ ] 15 bottles in
them carry them up stock each bar for
six bartenders start bringing up [ __ ]
garbage cans full of ice filling up the
troughs with ice bring it up cases of
beer stuff and the beers into the ice I
mean and then and then all sudden people
started trickling in around 9:30 10:00
crank the [ __ ] bad disco music power
pouring on the bikinis Guido's showing
up chicks that would I would have to
clean out the bathroom the women's
bathroom at least three times a day it'd
be clogged up with tampons these nasty
[ __ ] Guido chicks from Brooklyn would
stick their bloody tampons in there be
and then the men would throw [ __ ]
broken bottles into the urinals I'd have
to clean those out all day long up and
down and as the ice was down a flight of
stairs with a broken-down shitty ice
machine and all day long I weighed a
hundred and twenty-five pounds up and
down the stairs with buckets of ice on
my shoulder cases of Coors Light and
just fry and it was all outside so I was
getting fried from the Sun and I'm
thinking this is great I'm gonna get
laid I didn't get a [ __ ] conversation
with one of those chicks all summer long
all I did was drink Miller lights and
then a few times a day I'd run down to
the beach dive in the ocean and [ __ ]
cool off come back but I made Bank these
bartenders they knew I was taking care
of them and they were they were making
thousand dollars a day really yeah they
were making Cray
money and they would all tip me out so I
can you know 15 bartenders all tipping
one who's three of us me and two other
guys Wow and then I get on my bike at
around 6 o'clock and I pedal back to our
little flea infested studio apartment
and then take a shower and then we go to
this place
tequila Murphy's up the street and we
dance we [ __ ] dance to like you know
Rob base and DJ EZ rock that's right
the art of noise and we and I would
breakdance and we'd stay there till
[ __ ] 2:00 in the morning and I come
home get some more flea bites get up and
do it all over again every day
[Applause]
[Music]